hey guys pete here today i'm going to do
a better call saul video where i look at
the most popular theories
about how kim wexler's story will end
this has become one of the biggest
questions season 6 will answer
in a prequel show where we know where so
many characters will
end up kim's not being in breaking bad
leaves her fate wide open
in this video i'm gonna pick up where my
first kim video left off
i made that before the season 5 finale
so it talks about the different options
based on the evidence we
picked up through both series up until
that point
of course the ending of season 5 added a
whole other layer to things
it now seems like as good a time as any
to give it another look
first a spoiler warning i'm gonna talk
about everything that's happened and
better call saul through the fifth
season and everything that's happened in
the greater breaking bad universe
the better call saul official social
media accounts
asked fans what their favorite kim
theories were a couple of weeks ago
which include a lot of speculation i'll
be discussing
if any of this sounds troubling to you
this is your chance to leave
hit the subscribe button before you go
because i'll be covering the final
season with weekly videos just like
last time and something like monthly
solve videos until then
now let's get into it it's kind of crazy
how my best guess of what would happen
to kim
shifted throughout season 5. early on i
had a feeling that we might see her turn
the tables on jimmy and con
him essentially having the end of their
story be the conclusion of the season
then there were many twists and turns
along the way including a wedding that
was somewhat unexpected in the moment
and then her plan to go after howard at
the end
that was the big piece of info i didn't
have when i made the first video and
that became the thing that really makes
it hard to pin down where this is going
so what are the most popular kim
theories i'll refer to those social
media posts
on the official better call saul
accounts give you my thoughts on those
and then circle back to where i'm at and
my guess as of today
i guess it's not surprising that there
are a lot of fans that believe that she
still was saul behind the scenes
throughout the breaking bad timeline
basically we just never saw her because
we never saw saul
outside of his working relationship with
walt and jesse
i went into the details of this in my
previous video
and honestly i still don't really like
it showrunner peter gould has said in an
interview recently that the final season
will change the way we think about
breaking bad but i don't think this is
what he's getting at
it's not impossible but i think it would
involve too much retelling of that time
period which doesn't seem as likely as
it used to
based on where things were left there's
still a four year gap between the
timelines of the two shows that they
would have to skip over and the fact
that saul
uses ed's services to disappear with no
real indication that he's leaving
someone behind
that would require some explaining this
is a popular idea though
and as i said it's not surprising the
fans like kim
and they like kim and jimmy together
since they don't want to see something
bad happen to the character
they look for ways where she could still
be there as i mentioned in the first
video
ice station zebra associates is the best
evidence for this theory
watch that video if you want to hear
more about that and we'll come back to
this idea of her still being around in
the background in a minute
in contrast it's also a popular theory
that she'll die
considering that in the parlance of our
times she's in the game now
this truly is a possibility jimmy made
his bones transporting lalo's bail money
to become
a friend of the cartel and kim wound up
right there with him
she made herself known to lalo while he
was in custody and she stood up to him
when he showed up at their apartment
even though this would provide kim with
a definitive ending
i still tend to think that the writers
probably have something more complex in
mind
with how much she means to jimmy it's
hard to see him being the guy we know
from breaking bad if she's dead
especially if his involvement with the
cartel is
any way responsible it seems like
something that he would carry
with him and change who he fundamentally
is and not
in the direction of being someone who
likes being a
criminal lawyer like saul goodman does a
death would also
shut the door on any possibility of her
coming back into jimmy's life in the
gene timeline
post-breaking bad so i don't think this
is where the story is going
but i will concede that for that reason
it would be a shocking episode of
television if they did kill her off
since we're talking about the cartel i
should mention
some of the people who think she still
and saul's life off-screen
have a theory that she starts working
with the cartel
laundering money for lalo could tie her
into forming ice station zebra
associates
continuing to do that then for jimmy and
walt but i don't think it's likely
jimmy is still afraid of lalo when they
take him to the desert which means
something would have to happen to
end any working relationship kim was
involved with
could this happen i guess so is it one
of the best kim theories
not as far as i'm concerned and while
we're on the subject
in those posts there were quite a few
people suggesting that kim would run
away with lalo
or even nacho but to me those seem more
like
fanfic than real possibilities probably
the next most popular answer i saw in
those posts was that she will use
ed to disappear to leave town something
will happen with lalo and the cartel
or their plan to go after howard and
they'll have to make a call
to best quality vacuum and place an
order for
hoover max extract pressure pro model
60.
this would answer the question of how
jimmy learned about ed in the first
place
but i mean it seems like one too many
times to use this same ending to me
walt jesse and saul all got out of
albuquerque this way
so i hope they have something different
in mind for kim
another popular idea is that her own
recklessness will do her
in this has some grounding in that she's
escalating from just enjoying a con for
the thrill of it
to straight up scheming by the end of
season 5. she could take things too far
and going after howard to where she'd
have to leave
town it should be mentioned that robert
forrester who played ed
has passed away which means we won't
likely see him on screen again and as
mentioned
they've probably gone down this road
enough already
that could mean that she flees town
under different circumstances
or she might find herself in a situation
where the consequences catch up with her
going into the witness protection
program is an idea that might make sense
or perhaps you'll end up having to do
time it's not a stretch to imagine
kim taking responsibility if things go
wrong
i don't think that would be out of
character at all and there is a piece of
evidence that could support this
in the one better call saul scene that
we have that takes place during the
breaking bad timeline
the teaser in season 4 episode 5 quite a
ride
jimmy asked francesca to do him a favor
as they're fleeing from his law
office he says and where are you going
to be november 12th at 3 p.m
to which she responds i'll be there but
if it doesn't ring at 3 on the dot
i'm gone so there's a phone call it's
scheduled for that date which is jimmy's
birthday
and it's important enough that he wants
whoever's calling
to know that he would have been there if
he didn't have to leave town
it's hard to think of someone besides
kim that this could be
and the nature of the setup raises some
questions saul leaves albuquerque in
march
so this phone call is seven months down
the road that
in the fact that it's on his birthday
make it seem like a one-time or a once a
year occurrence
it also sounds like it's going to a
pre-arranged pay
phone we know saul is well aware of
burner phones he has a drawer full of
cell phones
in this office but for some reason this
call
needs to be taken at a pre-arranged
location
none of that amounts to a smoking gun
but it does seem like whoever's making
the call
is being monitored or at the very least
trying to keep their communication to a
minimum
in a way where it won't be able to be
used against them
one of the reasons i always come back to
this is because this
isn't the typical situation where
there's a reference
or a throwaway line from the original
series that bcs picks up and runs with
this is something that the writers came
up with and then injected
into the future timeline with an episode
teaser that they know
fans will pick apart it's there for a
reason there's no question about that
the question is whether
it is there to set up kim going to
prison or going into hiding in the
witness protection
program or otherwise if she's not still
in jimmy's life
she's not dead and she doesn't find
herself in big trouble
another theory to consider is that jimmy
does something
on purpose to force her away he
sabotages the relationship
in an effort to protect her
character-wise this could make sense
and it is an idea that's appealed to me
at different times
jimmy saul is a complicated character
he does and has done some awful things
but he's also pretty far from being
straight up evil
if you boil it down to a simple label
he's something like a con man with a
heart
what i like about the idea of him making
a decision to push her
in a way that she decides to leave him
is that he definitely loses something in
that
not just that he loses his partner a
relationship that does mean a lot to him
but he also loses the idea that he could
be something better
it's kind of a bummer when you think
about it like that but it would provide
the path to the behavior we've seen in
breaking bad
and so this is at least a possibility
the show does have a slightly different
situation where the end of the better
call saul timeline
isn't the end of the series we still
have the gene timeline
and the real end of the story will
happen there based on the end of season
5 we have to look at the flip side of
this
as well the theory that kim breaks bad
and that jimmy gets taken for a ride has
never been as popular
as it's been since she turned with those
finger guns in the finale
part of why we don't know what's gonna
happen to kim is because we don't really
know her we know she works hard
she's competent and that she grew
unsatisfied working for guys like kevin
at mesa birdie we know there's a side of
her that wants to do good through her
pro bono pd work
and that there's a side of her who gets
excited by pulling off cons with jimmy
beyond that in a few brief flashbacks we
don't really know about her past
she's generally the voice of reason when
jimmy takes things too far
but have we sort of assigned her this
role of being the moral center
when that's not really the case possibly
the sandpiper settlement could be
motivation
it's life-changing money jimmy did her
wrong leaving her
in the dark in his plan with mesa birdie
and he went directly against what she
asked him to do
if there was a moment when you might
expect her to break in this direction
that would be it but instead she doubled
down on the relationship
she proposed they get married and then
followed through with that
now there are popular theories out there
that the wedding itself was part of the
plan
a lot of that hinges on her behavior at
the courthouse
and that weird pause and mention of her
not having a middle name during the
ceremony
this would be a hell of a twist and
would also pave the way for jimmy to go
full
saul there's enough there that if they
did go this way you could go back
and find some clues but i'm still not
personally convinced
i think they could certainly pull it off
but a part of me doesn't want to accept
it and for what it's worth
my takeaway from the wedding scene was
that she was actually into it
the final theory is the oldest theory
and one that just gets harder to imagine
as the story goes on
the idea that kim will finally get fed
up with jimmy's turning into saul
and her finally deciding to leave him
for the entirety of the first four
seasons
this is what fans were waiting for what
was the thing gonna be that would
finally make her decide to leave him
where was that exact
moment where he became soul and then she
rejects him
for everything that i just said i don't
really think that's where things are
going
she's had plenty of opportunities at
this point and she's always
chose to double down she's always chose
to lean into the relationship
rather than walking away i've mentioned
the gene timeline a few
times so i'll just say that it's a very
popular theory that kim will return
in the gene timeline there's different
ideas ranging from
she's already there when she left
albuquerque she went to
nebraska since that's where she's from a
pretty unlikely one is that she's
working right inside the
same mall and they run into each other
or she just happens to show up at this
mall
and comes into gene's store for a
cinnabon if she was in hiding
or in prison maybe jean is just biting
his time until she can come there and
they can get back together
and then of course the theory that gene
gets himself in trouble
and kim comes in to be his lawyer so i
think those are most of the popular
ideas that are floating around
there are some silly ones out there like
she becomes windy
in the breaking bad timeline or she goes
off and changes her name
and becomes the character that she
played in franklin and bash
i don't think either one of those is
very likely so i guess the only thing
left to do
is tell you where my thoughts are right
at the moment
and i'll do that right after this
i want to take a minute to tell you
about the sponsor of today's video
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of
inspiring classes for creative and
curious people explore new skills
develop existing interests and get lost
in creativity i'm currently working
through the course
advanced video editing with adobe
premiere pro 2020 by jordy vandeput i
like how he clearly explains the
different topics and i learned a couple
of tricks that will really speed up my
editing process
if you're uncertain about what's next
creative challenges and productivity
classes can be a great way to help you
structure your time and set
up achievable goals at a time when so
many important conversations are
happening in our world your voice is
more essential than ever
explore classes to unlock your
creativity for social good
skillshare offers memberships with
meaning connect with the support of
fellow creatives
and enter a community of encouragement
communication and inspiration
whether you're looking to fend off
boredom focus on self-care through
creativity or join a similarly creative
community skillshare is the place to
keep you learning
the first 1000 people to use the link in
my description will get a free trial of
skillshare premium membership
and after that it's only around 10 a
month so check it out
i think you'll like it my thinking as of
right now is that kim will throw herself
into this plan to destroy howard
enforce the sandpiper payout i think
season six will pick up right where the
finale of season five left off and i
don't think there'll be anything to stop
her from moving in that direction
i think jimmy will be reluctant at first
possibly even trying to steer her away
from it but eventually he'll start
getting the high
from doing what he's so good at and
we'll see them working together at the
top of their game the thing i keep going
back to
is this idea that kim is the kind of
character who likes to be in control
she likes to have everything laid out in
front of her because she feels like
there's nothing that she can't do
and she has this other tendency to not
want to have anybody help her she wants
to do everything herself she wants to
control the situation that way
you don't save me i save me you don't
fix it i
fix it and i think this will end up
bringing her down
it's hard to pin myself down to one
thing but if i had to say today
i would say i think she's gonna probably
end up in prison there could be a chance
that jimmy could
turn things around or he could take the
fall
but she won't let him do it and the
reason we don't see her during breaking
bad is because she's locked up
the telephone call that francesca will
be waiting for is gonna be her
she'll be released at some point in the
future but
you know jimmy will have to go into
hiding and he'll be out there being gene
which will leave things open for her to
return in that timeline
pretty much any of the things i just
mentioned could happen though so i'm
really
interested to hear where you're at what
your favorite kim theory is
what you think's gonna happen and better
call saul season six
in general what are you hoping to see
what is the ending that you just
wouldn't be able to accept for kim
let me know that and anything else in
the comments please like this video if
you enjoyed
it please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
check out my other better call saul
videos and come back
and watch season six with me thanks for
watching i'll talk to you soon